the circle x squared plus y squared
minus eight x equals zero and the
hyperbola x squared over nine minus y
squared over four equal one intersect at
the points a and b
equation of a common tangent with
positive slope so of a common tangent
with positive slope to the circle as
well to the hyperbola is so let's just
visualize what they're asking first and
this is going to take us multiple videos
i have a feeling but let's just
visualize it just so we can get our head
around the problem so this circle let me
complete the square in terms of x so
this circle as they wrote as x squared
minus eight x and then we have a plus y
squared i left some space here so that
we can complete the square is equal to
zero and then let me add half of this
eight term squared to both sides so half
of negative eight is negative four
negative four squared is 16.
so add 16 to both sides and that allowed
me to turn
the x term into a complete into a square
perfect square this is the same thing as
x
minus 4 squared and then we have plus y
squared
plus y squared is equal to
16.
so this is a circle this right here is a
circle with
center
at x is equal to zero sorry at x equals
four
at x equals four y is equal to zero and
it has a radius
it has a radius of 4 as well so let me
graph
let me graph this circle here
so let me draw the horizontal axis my
x-axis
let me draw the y-axis
that is my y-axis over here and let me
draw its center so one two three four
four comma zero that's its center it has
a radius of four so it's going to come
out it's going to look something
it's going to look something i could
draw a better circle than that it's
going to look something like
that's the top half and then the bottom
half is going to look something like
that so that's our circle now let's
think about the hyperbola let's think
about the hyperbola so if we just look
at it the x squared term is positive so
it's going to be a hyperbola that opens
to the right and the left we do this a
bunch in the conic sections videos if
you want a review of that and we could
just figure out where
where it intersects the x-axis so then
when y is equal to zero we have x
squared over nine must be equal to one
or x would be plus or minus three so the
hyperbola is going to look like this so
this is at plus three comma zero the
hyperbola will open up like that
will open up like that and then it
one two
three negative three comma zero the
hyperbola is going to open up
to the left
and so in the problem when they describe
the points a and b they're probably
talking about that point a
and that point b now let's think about
what this question is asking us equation
of a common tangent with positive slopes
has to have a positive slope to the
circle as well as to the hyperbola a
common tangent
so let's just think about this a little
bit so it's going to have a positive
slope so it's going to have to so it
won't it won't be tangent to the circle
anywhere where the circle has a negative
slope so it can't be tangent it can't be
tangent over here can't be tangent over
there
and then we could say well what if it
was tangent to the circle over here what
would happen well it would wouldn't be
able to be tangent it wouldn't be able
to be tangent to the hyperbola so it has
to be the tenth it has to be tangent to
the circle someplace
someplace in this blue region
right over here and then how can it be
tangent to the hyperbola it might be
tempting to say that it would be tangent
to the hyperbola in this way
in this way somehow what you need to
realize is the hyperbola is asymptoting
towards some line and we could figure
out we could figure out what that line
is
it's asymptoting towards some line so
let me draw that line
it's asymptotic and so it's always it's
always going to have the hyperbola is
always going to have a higher slope than
that line it's a
very slightly higher slope it's slowly
approaching that line so if you go out
here the hyperbola is going to have a
higher slope than that than the
asymptote line and so if you had to be
tangent to it you would have to have a
higher slope
you would have to have a higher slope
and anything that's coming from this
part of the circle towards anything out
here on the hyperbola is going to have
to have a lower slope than the tangent
line right because it's going to have to
catch up the tangent line is going to
have to catch up to whatever to whatever
let me draw it again to whatever we draw
over here i want to make this clear
the hyperbola the hyperbola as you go
out here actually this whole period this
whole area this whole part of the
hyperbola is going to have a higher
slope than what it is asymptoting
towards that's what allows it to get
closer and closer to that line so any
tangent is going to have to have a
higher slope
out here anything tangent to the
hyperbola is going to have to have a
higher slope than this actual line it's
going to have to have a slightly higher
slope
so if we take something out here and we
try to draw a tangent from this part of
the circle out there it wouldn't work
because this this tangent by definition
will have to
in order to meet the hyperbola is going
to have to have a lower slope than this
asymptote so this can't be tangent to
that part of the hyperbola so what else
can we do well the only other part of
the hyperbola that we might be able to
work something out is is this part of
the hyperbola
right over here so if we find
if we find a line that's tangent maybe
there and there
on the hyperbola then we might have
found our common tangent with positive
slope so let me draw that so our common
tangent with positive slope let me do
that in i'll do that in pink our common
tangent with positive slope
could
look like that so now that we have the
visualization down in the next video
let's try to figure out let's figure out
what that what that line might look like
especially when we constrain it by
well when we constrain it to having to
be tangent to the circle and having to
be tangent to this hyperbola